[Musique]
et les histoires ne voient pas les sorcières comme vraies ce
qu'elles disent que les elfes sont la
sorcière originale du continent quand les humains
et les monstres sont arrivés,
sinon vous avez dit que vous deviez parler de chaos à
la magie et les humains les ont regardés le
chaos est la chose la plus dangereuse  dans
ce monde
mais sans contrôle le chaos vous tuera
alors c'est comme ça pour vous les monstres
et l'argent c'est tout ce qu'il faut pour moi
quelque chose là-bas poids frais
cet enfant sera extraordinaire
Jennifer imaginez la femme la plus puissante
du monde
avez-vous ce qu'il  prends
tu ne peux pas dépasser le destin juste parce que
tu en es terrifié ça vient
je ne peux pas faire ça sans
toi de ce que tu choisis